all right any day now hundreds of court
documents related to Jeffrey Epstein
will be made public now the unsealed
records will include more than 150 names
of individuals who had ties to the
convicted pedophile Now ABC News has
reported that Bill Clinton will be
identified as John Doe 36 with his name
apparently mentioned more than 50 times
Clinton is one of many prominent names
expected to appear in the court filings
we did reach out to Bill Clinton's
office for comment and we were referred
to his statement from 2019 when the
former president admitted to traveling
on Epstein's plane says he never visited
his Infamous Island and his office notes
that Clinton has not been accused of any
wrongdoing anyway here with reaction
Tennessee senator Marsha Blackburn well
according to one of the victims who's
writing a book and an expert excert
showing up in the Daily Mail uh it
suggests that Bill Clinton was there I
guess time will prove that um I'm I'm
hearing last minute that there might
have been a delay one of the John Do's
quote uh claiming that the mention of
their name may bring them physical harm
have you heard that
Senator we have not heard that but Sean
I would expect that that is what is
happening and thank you for continuing
to bring attention to this issue you
know this is not a list that anyone
wants their name to be on and there are
going to be people there on this list
that are accused of wrongdoing there are
going to be those on the list who are
accusing Epstein and Maxwell of
wrongdoing and there be people that were
witnesses to some of this activity but
did not report that activity so I'm
certain that Bill Clinton and other
people are very nervous uh they don't
want to be on this list there are people
that are going to be ashamed that they
are and he's probably one of them the
only one I could think of that might be
on the list is Alan dtz who was an
attorney everybody has a right to
Council he did have charges brought up
against him and he's been adamant uh in
his denial of any wrongdoing or any
knowledge of even the things that have
happened there why is this important to
get out to the public in your
view you know it is so important that we
figure out what happened with this sex
trafficking ring this human trafficking
ring you've been talking about the
border and the cartels and the amount of
human trafficking and Sean we know that
human trafficking and sex trafficking
has gone from being about a $500 million
a year business a few years ago to
upwards of 150 billion dollars a year
this is modern-day slavery there are
women and children that need this
protection this is not about celebrity
it's about criminal activity it's
getting to the bottom of what is going
on and seeing who was Affiliated and
associated with Jeffrey Epstein so we
break these sex trafficking rings
all right Senator we'll stay on it I
promise hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else